good afternoon my name is with the other
I'm managing trustee at cap I'm an
entrepreneur myself i co-founded
distrust I also co-founded a management
consulting company which isn'ta niqab
ranchers also co-founded an IT and
software company named Cygnus IT
solutions this has been the second year
that have participated at India economic
summit it's been a great event so far
have been diversified peoples I
versified panel is diversified audience
all including of people all walks of
life you know people have been some
sports from academics from politicians
to bureaucrats it's been great to reach
all these people learn from them a lot
of issues have been have been discussed
and lot of steps have been taken in
terms of how to improve the governance
in India how to improve the economic
situation how to increase GDP how to get
back to a high growth rate all these
things have been a doctor pond or
discuss upon what are the solutions
specifically you have been asked to
debate upon on their insides their
vision for India so it's been a great
event I looked over for some more
excitement for the entire rest of the
event thanks